cinco millares es igual a cuántas
centenas hay varias formas en las que
podemos resolver esto pero comencemos
pensando en estos cinco millares cinco
millares es un millar o mil multiplicado
por cinco
así que pensemos en cada uno de estos
cinco millares cuántas centenas hay en
un millar un millar es igual a cuántas
centenas pues contemos las centenas
hasta llegar a un millar vamos a hacer
algunas marcas para llevar la cuenta de
nuestras centenas 100 200 300 400 500
600 700 800 900 mil por lo que
necesitamos 10 centenas para llegar a
1000 o a un millar así que un millar es
igual a 10 centenas a que será igual
cinco millares o cinco mil pues cinco
millares o cinco mil cinco veces mil por
lo que también vamos a tener cinco veces
esto de aquí
lo que tendremos cinco veces las
centenas que tenemos aquí así que cinco
millares o cinco mil es igual a cinco
por diez centenas ya que tenemos cinco
mil y aquí tendremos cinco veces las
centenas equivalentes cinco veces diez
centenas o cinco por 10 50 por lo que
cinco millares o cinco mil es igual a
cincuenta centenas otra forma en la que
podemos pensar en esto es en el valor
posicional vamos a hacerlo
veamos nuestra tabla de posiciones de
valor aquí tenemos nuestra tabla y aquí
ponemos nuestros cinco millares y
podemos ver que tenemos tres lugares
vacíos aquí no tenemos antenas ni
decenas ni unidades por lo que tenemos
que llenar esto con ceros o cinco mil el
escribir la palabra millares reemplaza a
estos tres ceros de aquí cinco millares
es lo mismo que tener cinco mil este
cinco con los tres ceros al final
queremos cambiar estos cinco millares
por centenas a leer esta tabla
posicional cuando vemos el 5 y nos
detenemos aquí el 5 es el último número
que leemos tendremos que leer el valor
posicional que está arriba millares para
centenas haremos lo mismo vamos a leer
el número hasta las centenas y después
leeremos el valor de esa última posición
de nuestro número así que cinco millares
es lo mismo que cincuenta centenas cinco
millares o cinco mil es igual a
cincuenta centenas y no tenemos que
incluir estos ceros al final porque de
la misma forma que con millares
representábamos estos tres ceros al
final con la palabra centenas estamos
representando estos dos ceros al final
así que cinco millares es lo mismo que
cincuenta centenas no nos preguntan por
decenas pero las podemos ver aquí
podemos decir que tenemos quinientos
decenas leemos el número hasta las
decenas y después leemos el valor
de esta posición que son decenas y ya no
incluimos este 0 al final porque está
implícito en la palabra decenas y
finalmente si quisiéramos leer el número
completo diríamos cinco mil unidades o
cinco millares de unidades así que
cualquiera de estos cinco millares
cincuenta centenas quinientos decenas o
cinco mil unidades son lo mismo todas
son equivalentes pero lo que nos
preguntaron fueron centenas por lo que
cinco millares es igual a cincuenta
centenas
aquí hay otro ejemplo 30 decenas es
igual a cuántas centenas en esta ocasión
estamos viendo decenas y nos preguntan
centenas veamos cómo se relacionan las
decenas y las centenas cuantas decenas
hay en una centena y podemos escribir
una centena con la palabra o con el
número pues si no lo sabemos podemos
calcularlo contando decenas hasta llegar
a unas centenas
cuantas decenas necesitamos para llegar
a una centena
vamos a contar las 10 20 30 40 50 60 70
80 90 100 necesitamos 10 decenas para
llegar a una centena hay 10 decenas en
una centena y si hay 10 escenas en una
centena cuántas centenas habrá en 30
decenas pues para pasar de 10 decenas a
30 decenas tenemos que multiplicar esto
por 3 por lo que también tendremos que
multiplicar por 3
es las centenas que tenemos aquí es
decir tres centenas tres decenas es un
conjunto de tres centenas diez decenas
es una centena por lo que tres conjuntos
de diez decenas es igual a tres centenas
o tres centenas también podemos pensar
en esto en términos del valor posicional
aquí tenemos las decenas y sabemos que
están representadas por un cero así que
en lugar de treinta decenas podemos
escribir un 30 con un 0 al final es el
cero de las decenas y aquí esto sería
igual a centenas y sabemos que las
centenas están representadas con dos
ceros y para hacer esto equivalente qué
número tendremos que poner en este lugar
pues la respuesta nuevamente es un 3
como lo resolvimos aquí arriba así que
30 decenas es igual a tres centenas